How often should I get two markers done?
Let me answer that one first. Well, it depends. So if your two more markers are again, it's just like blood work.
Oh, like if you're two more markers on your CDC and your complete metabolic panel is all in perfect range, it hasn't been in the past.
Then you know, let's say we were doing it every month, then we then I spread it to every two months. It looks really good.
That's going to three months or four months, and they're going to go to six months.
You know, and then you make decisions, you know, partly upon how you're feeling. Like, you know, I haven't done, you know, I know that entrepreneur told me I'm not supposed to get my blood test done for six months, but your four months into it.
Let's hear just not feeling well. And it's been a few weeks. You don't feel well. Then you should go and get a test. It don't wait.
So with tumor marker tests, again, those can change pretty fast, but, you know, it's not like unless you're insurance paid for it.
I don't know that the doctor will order it unless there is some reason to order it. You can order it from us.
They're like a hundred bucks or something like that, but still a hundred dollars if you don't need to do it.
So it depends on, you know, what we're where they're at and how long they've been within normal range and such.
Those are how you help make that decision. What kind of scans should I ask for? Well, that depends on how invasive you're willing to be and how, you know,
because the invasiveness of a scan, if you're going to do an MRI, it's typically going to be with contrast.
So you're going to have gadolidium excess gadolidium over time and be ish can be a major issue.
You're going to do CT scan. That's a lot of radiation. So as a pet scan and a lot of radiation.
So and again, it depends, you know, I have patients that are like, I didn't do any of those any more ever. I just don't need that.
I think that's not helping me recover. So it and I've had other patients like, no, I just I need to know, I need to know because of, you know, you can't ignore the emotional issues behind serious disease.
So everybody's going to make their own decision with that. But, you know, you know, doing, you know, CT scans every six months or a pet scan every six months to a year just to satisfy curiosity.
It's probably not very good for us. So it should be based upon other non or less invasive signs and symptoms.
So your blood tests are within normal range. You're feeling great. No, we're not going to do another CT scan.
So just to make sure, you know, because they're invasive and they're not good for us. So we should be listening to those things.
Is an ultrasound valve valuable at all with having had a double mastectomy? No, maybe to other parts of your body, if you do an ultrasound to your axillary area, your areas, if you're thinking that you have a mast there.
So, but to the chest wall, no, you're just going to see your ribs and things. I don't think that's going to be a value there.
What about those whole body MRIs that don't require Galilean? Yes, that's called Produvo.
Your chair says it paid for that. So that's going to be all cash out of pocket. But those are excellent. That's what I had.
So that was my last scan. And it does the last time I did that was it'll be three years now this spring will be three years.
And so those are those are great. You know, there's only, I don't know, nine to eight or nine or something around the country.
So you'd have to travel to where it is. But you can self-schedule that and make sure an appointment to do that.
So those are great. Those are called Produvo.
He has said those are still up in the year, but do you have any insight? So your colleges has said those are still up in the air, because they have an investigative. They're extremely accurate.
Those are really good tests, but they're just because the insurance companies and because the because the insurance companies are tied so tightly to the manufacturers of equipment and drug companies, there's nobody to be made out of. So they haven't covered them yet.
Um, just getting regular blood work, I think, is a good thing to do. That's something that is often overlooked and make sure you send it to me and make sure that we go over on a fairly regular basis.
I got somebody's blood work in early last week. And they sent me their blood work. It was from September. And when I looked at it, there was some abnormalities.
And I think I talked about this last two call, but nobody ever talked about it. So I see this. You know, wait, times I see this all the time where people get blood work done.
And then why do you order the blood work? If you don't talk to the person about the blood work. So if you're going to send me blood work, it's your responsibility to make an appointment with me to schedule to talk about it if you if I didn't order it.
So if I didn't order your blood work and you got them from your oncologist, I'm kind of making the assumption that they discuss these things with you, which is really a stupid assumption.
I'm finding it. So but if you want somebody to go over, I'll gladly go over with you, but I don't want to sound like I'm like, you know, pushing you for office visits or something like that.
I want you to know what's going on in your blood work. So you can help to serve your course of care and what's going on with you. And also look at the chronic disease and autoimmune course, because I have a lot of videos on helping understand some different blood work that could be helpful for you as well to self understand them.